Hillary Clinton unexpectedly lost the states
of Pennsylvania, Ohio, Michigan, Wisconsin,
and Iowa.
Those are states that have gone Democratic
in past elections.
The question is, why did they switch this
time?
The reasons really, you can look for them
in the “out states” of those regions,
in central and western Pennsylvania, outside
Pittsburgh and Philadelphia, outside Cleveland,
Columbus and Cincinnati, Ohio, outside Detroit
and Grand Rapids, Michigan, outside Milwaukee
and Madison, Wisconsin and the whole state
of Iowa.
What hurt Hillary Clinton there?
Number one: the economy.
These are areas that feel left behind.
Donald Trump appealed to them with his program.
Number two was condescension.
Hillary Clinton called people voting for Trump
"deplorables" and "irredeemables," "implicit
racists."
That doesn't win you votes.
And the third thing was honesty.
The out states went heavily against Richard
Nixon and the Republicans during Watergate.
They went against Hillary Clinton and her
secret email server and the Democrats in 2016.